not as clumsy or random as a blaster an
elegant weapon for a more civilized day
well what do you have to say about that
video games
hello Internet well welcome to game
theory where to answer all your
questions one more time the red in the
logo is not a reference to the xbox red
ring of death why would I do that as
some sort of weekly warning against the
hubris of game console manufacturers as
a loving reminder of all those times you
had to cuddle your Xbox 360 under a
blanket in a last-ditch effort to get it
to function nope it's just a reference
to my other channel film theory which
has read in that part of the logo oh it
makes so much sense now and lately on
film theory I like the rest of the
internet have been covering a lot of
Star Wars which means my mind has been
swimming in Jedi battles and galactic
terrorism as blades which leads us to
today's episode because as I was
researching the physics of the
lightsaber I couldn't help but think
about another iconic weapon one we all
know and love from gaming the halo
energy sword and once I really started
thinking about it a good shake how
similar these two weapons actually are
I mean seriously these aren't just two
iconic laser sword weapons they're more
like brothers from different mothers but
as it is with all twin brothers now that
they've finally been reunited we're
gonna have to decide right here and
right now which one would win in a fight
right
the thing that siblings do I'm an only
child so I don't really know I'm
assuming it's a thing and before we get
too far I want to make it absolutely
clear that this theory is exclusively
focused on the weapons alone not the
characters who wield them were we to
open the door to that well then we'd
have to talk about midi-chlorians and no
one wants to talk about midi-chlorians
not even Star Wars apparently so in
order to start comparing the weapons and
decide which one would win in a fight we
need to understand how they would
potentially work in the real world when
it comes to the energy sword halo has
already done most of the work for us
according to the halo encyclopedia the
blades of the weapon are made of plasma
contained around the edge of the sword
by magnetic fields now we've talked
about plasma before on film theory since
it's the closest real-world basis for
all of Dragon Balls energy attacks but
just to catch every one a plasma is the
most abundant form of matter
making up 99% of the universe but what
is it you know when you heat up a solid
it melts and becomes a liquid and then
you heat it up a bit more and it becomes
the gas well if you heat the gas even
more it becomes plasma we're most
familiar with it in the form of
lightning stars and florescent bulbs but
basically by heating the gas the
electrons of the atoms get so excited
that they break away this creates a soup
of negatively charged electrons floating
around alongside positively charged ions
the halo energy source then at its most
basic level takes this soup and controls
it using magnets shaping the superheated
gas around the blades of the weapon but
what's an energy sword without energy
well it's actually just a sword yeah and
that's why batteries are included hahaha
puberty and that's why batteries are
included in each new weapon
suck on that Mattel the future is now
changing a gas to a plasma takes a lot
of energy so the battery enables this to
happen by shooting an electric current
through the gas allowing it to change
its state in much the same way that a
plasma cutter works and thus you have
your battery operated death sword a
pretty cool thing to look forward to in
the future right not really
plasma blades are something being rolled
out in medicine for things like surgery
as we speak so this idea isn't so much
science fiction
as it is just plain old science
explaining the lightsaber though is
actually a bit trickier since well it's
neither light nor saber let's take it
one at a time light is made up of
particles known as photons they're
constantly flying all over the universe
they have no mass and generally don't
react with one another that's why you
can cross flashlight beams with no
difference in the light that's being
produced sure I suppose you could shoot
light through a cloud of super cold
rubidium gas which gets the photons to
act more like molecules creating a new
state of matter called photonic
molecules but it's a fringe case that's
still being tested by science and
seriously who do we think we are German
experimental physicist Gustav Ludvig
Hirst
come on we're not the other problem with
light sabers made of light is that
currently science has a hard time
telling photons when to stop moving so
if a light saber were truly made of
light and without a mirror or something
at the end of the sword to stop the beam
it would extend a much longer distance
than a few feet I guess in that case you
wouldn't have to compare sizes though
and I see your forces as big as mine and
again just like high powered flashlights
or lasers a light saber of Lights
wouldn't actually clash with another
light saber they would just ask through
each other and you would shine it in
each other's eyes but we cause like
night blindness so anyway it's not a
lightsaber nor is it a laser saber
then what is it well more likely than
not it's a plasma saber but again not a
saber either since a saber is a Calvary
sword with a curved blade and one
cutting edge curved nope only one
cutting edge I dare you to touch that
thing so more like a short sword no
that's not right plasma wushu sword
plasma epi plasma rapier plasma katana
you know there's really no sword like
equivalent to a lightsaber honestly it's
more like plasma bludgeoning stick but
why plasma well currently the same
system operating the energy sword makes
the most sense for the lightsaber a
magnetic field shaping a superheated
tube of gas midi-chlorians are no the
behavior lines up in Star Wars Episode
one The Phantom Menace qui-gon jinn uses
his lightsaber to melt through a blast
meaning the lightsaber is getting above
2500 degrees Fahrenheit or 13 70 degrees
Celsius
now look at the temperature of plasma
even quote-unquote cold plasma is
several thousand degrees Celsius so it
have no problem accomplishing this task
what about different colors of light see
well the different colors of gas used to
form the plasma could create the rainbow
of colors you see in lightsabers helium
for mace windu to produce his purple
color argon for Darth Maul and his dark
red saber and cf4 for Luke Skywalker's
heroic blue and because plasma is an
actual state of matter unlike a blade of
light here the sabers would clash just
like you see throughout the iconic sword
battles in the movies and games this
idea is also supported by theoretical
physicist and all-around scientific
badass dr. Michio Kaku and if you needed
any further proof although the movies
don't ever mention plasma the games do
to quote Star Wars The Old Republic the
weapon consists of a blade of pure
plasma energy emitted from the metal
hilt and suspended in a force
containment field
boom decades of cannon for this classic
film series and yet it's the games where
we get the most information about how
these iconic weapons would work video
games for the win long story short when
you actually look at the science the
lightsaber and energy sword are one in
the same so if they're basically the
same device which one would win well as
similar as the tech behind them is these
blades couldn't be designed any more
differently unless your name is either
kylo Ren or Darth Maul the lightsaber
blade tends to be a relatively thin and
modest rod a variable length well the
energy sword is actually two triangular
blades with an opening that runs down
into the center towards the quote
unquote hilt so which design comes out
on top because lightsabers have a more
basic and variable design it opens up a
lot of different fighting styles and
since the blade is plasma all the weight
is in the hill according to the now
legendary article called flight saber
from issue 62 the Star Wars insider and
the Jedi Academy training manual we know
that there are seven main styles of
lightsaber combat each style has its own
emphasis on specific tactics or
defensive techniques but one commonality
across nearly all of them is an emphasis
on ampie
Haitian moods strokes that will sever
limbs most notable of these is the Cho
my strike which single-handedly resulted
in so many single hands in the Star Wars
universe padam Ching give us a whomp aw
come on the Wawa poor thing for the
energy sword it's a bit more complicated
because there's so much less information
on the way elites actually use it to
fight so we can't put together a good
guess based on history and its design
firstly let's look at the gap between
the two sides of the blade the gap
always narrows almost to the point of
touching just before you get to the area
where your hand is as if the opponent's
blade is meant to slide right into that
slot and that's exactly right
this split structure allows the fighter
to trap their opponent's blade so the
elite can twist it either disarming the
enemy or leaving them open for the
killing blow it's an idea that's been
proven throughout history most notably
by the parrying daggers from the late
Middle Ages and early Renaissance for
instance take a look at this 16th
century German Trident dagger whose
blade Springs open into three precisely
because trapping the opponent's blade is
such a good idea like a Schick razor
commercial why have one blade when you
can have seven no one suspects the
Trident dagger or look at the sword
breakers which had small teeth like a
comb near the hill where an opponent's
sword would slide in and get stuck so
it's an offensive weapon that also has
defensive properties but the other
benefit of energy sword is that both
sides of the blades extend almost
completely around the wielders hands
even extending down beyond the wrist
into sharpened points in a battle with a
straight lightsaber used mostly for
disarming or should i say dis handing
the opponent this design detail is a
huge benefit to the energy sword it
almost makes it seem like the energy
sword that was designed specifically as
a counter to the Jomon strikes of the
lightsaber so when it comes strictly to
design the wind has to go to halo so
then that's it right it would look like
the halo energy sword is the winner
based on its design
well there's one big issue we haven't
explored yet better
check your CNET review score on that new
plasma sword my friends because just
like most other portable electronics in
the end it comes down to battery life
you heard that right
break out the charging stations for your
beam swords these things need some
energy sources deep in the extended
universe lore it's revealed that during
the ancient history of Star Wars
lightsabers had to be powered through an
extension cord that was connected to a
bulky battery pack worn on the jedis
belts these would go on to be known as
proto sabers and man can you think about
how lame battles in the movies would be
if they were still using these guys I
mean just cut the cord or force grab the
battery pack and all your opponent is
left with is a handle eventually the
design evolved into what we know today
with the power source moving into the
hilt and now you've got fights like duel
of the fates from Phantom Menace where
Jedi are fighting for what seems like
several hours at a time but even still
Padawans wanted that proto saber
according to the jedi academy training
manual a member of Luke Skywalker's Jedi
Order actually went on to revive the
proto saber that's right it's the
definition of a Jedi hipster oh wow the
retro Way was so much better let's bring
this thing back even though it's clearly
inferior to what we currently have this
could potentially even show up in the
new movies this character was an order
of luke's jedi order after all wouldn't
that be just just so-so weird
I hope you also wears like flannel robes
and thick rimmed glasses that don't
actually have a prescription in them
maybe some tight Jedi leggings jeggings
anyway that said even the most poultry
battery life of a lightsaber would drown
that of the energy sword which lasts as
all you feel Oh fans no 10 whopping
swings before you're left weaponless
holding the equivalent of a weird alien
shake wait
so that makes it taste clothes then
rights despite design superiority the
lackluster energy supply of the
ironically named energy sword loses to
even the most low-tech of proto Sabre
but hold on to your rat's tail qui gonn
because after doing the research tensed
wings may be more than enough time for
our elite to finish off a saber wielding
remember our ground rules at the
beginning that in this contest no
consideration would be given to any
force power we're talking strictly
design and function of the blades and
though a 10 swing battery might sound
like it sucks in the real world without
force powers or respawning when two
people fight each other with swords the
fight only ever lasts a minute or two
and most of that time isn't spent
swinging swords around frantically it's
spent poking each other at a distance
just think about fencing you guys
clearly watch those rights I mean
they're pretty awesome so you should
especially during the Olympics they're
incredible anyway let me tell you in
fencing matches rarely if ever are you
getting to ten swings contact is made
within one or two jabs usually in fact
most experts out there today believe
that most actual sword fights never even
get to the point where someone would try
to do a two-handed swing because of how
completely dangerous it is to do it
leaves you wide open instead fights if
they did happen had one or two clashes
of Steel at most before someone was on
the ground bleeding out and in this
situation under these rules in the
argument of lightsabers versus energy
swords it's actually halo that comes out
on top yes the battery life might suck
but design superiority wins the day
although let me be clear I love them
both don't pull a death battle and rain
down a lot of hate on me this is really
just meant to be a thought experiment
where I could teach you about plasma and
light energy and sword design I'm not
saying that one is like cooler than the
other or whatever I'm saying in the
battle between two fictional swords that
are basically the same but designed
slightly differently this one functions
slightly better than this other one okay
I'm still gonna get a lot of heat for
this episode aren't I but hey that's
just a theory a game theory thanks for
watching hey if you enjoy Star Wars then
you'll love audible.com where you can
find audio books of all sorts of
expanded universe material as well as
getting yourself a sneak preview of the
upcoming movies in the franchise want to
relive the force awakens ooh they have
it an unabridged book form want to know
more about this guy from the movie the
mysterious Darth Plagueis download Star
Wars Darth
yes and get ready to shock your friends
with your predictions of what role he's
gonna play in the next movie don't worry
I won't tell them where you got the
information from well was audible.com so
I'll tell them about audible.com but I
won't tell them that you had listened to
the book where you got you know let's
let's just continue shall we they have
the x-wing Series legacy of the four
series all waiting for you to listen to
and for you guys who like
behind-the-scenes stuff the secret
history of Star Wars like a film theory
title waiting to happen all of them are
on audible.com I cannot recommend their
audiobook service enough they've been
regular sponsors of the show for a while
now when their financial help allows me
to produce more videos for you but
beyond that listening to audiobooks in
the car helps me do a lot of research
for episodes like this because the
reading is really valuable in life but
sometimes you just don't have the time
or wanna sit down and hold a physical
book you're busy doing other stuff so
having a book playing in the background
just makes sense hey you know what if
you're sick of Star Wars they have over
a hundred and eighty thousand titles to
download across all genres of books so
I'm sure you're gonna find something
that you like if not you're too picky
for your own good go out and expand your
horizons Plus to make the deal even
sweeter they're offering a 30-day free
trial so you can binge listen your way
through as many books as possible all
you have to do is go to audible.com
slash matpat to download the book of
your choice for free and remember doing
so helps all of us on the channel too
because it shows audible that we're a
valuable partner to them
so go ahead learn about Darth Plagueis
by going to audible.com for your free
30-day trial
that's audible.com slash em 80 P 80 or
just click the link in the description
Tellem matpat Sencha while you do that
by typing in the URL or clicking the
link in the description so do one of
those things and tell them through the
data that matpat sent you you understand
the concept great Coolio's next theory
is undertale by the way spoiler alert